i told you about how i was in
the the wwe ring on monday night raw
and um i i strongly suspect
that they went like harder on
me they're the one guy umaga i mean
granted of course because
the match was supposed to be over and i
kept moving around
and that i didn't realize is a sign of
disrespect and so he really
like beat me into a blackout i actually
do not remember leaving the ring
but even before that earlier in the
match
i suspected that he was like maybe
making some kind of a point i've heard
somebody
suggest that when like celebrities or
like you know non like real
wrestlers get in the ring that they
almost like go harder on them like
they're
like uh want to make it
well i mean there's just so many
unspoken
rules there's so much unspoken that like
everyone's expected to know but like how
the hell are you supposed to know
kind of a thing and i think there's also
like a chip on people's shoulder
thinking that they don't get the respect
that they deserve for what they do so a
lot of times
from outside and they think like oh yeah
this is whatever tip tap [ __ ]
take whatever's and people kind of have
that
chip on their shoulder to prove to them
like hey this is tough stuff
and this is something you should take
seriously
and there was like you know these
unspoken rules like you were saying
you're trying to flail around
and show oh my god this hurts so much
but you're supposed to lay dead
but because you didn't know that
unspoken rule they beat the [ __ ] out of
you until you laid down which is like
kind of what i don't know like in like
pro wrestling there's like uh
like almost like a hazing to kind of get
you to think the way that they want you
to think and adapt
this to system and way of thinking and
so if you kind of like walk into the
back door and you don't
know any of that there's just so much of
like
like uh etiquette that makes perfect
sense
that makes total sense and um of course
like they're not gonna be like harder on
like you know random celebrities that go
in there but when it's like
a couple [ __ ] from jackass saying
that we're like the toughest stunt
people
of course they went so hard on us you
know
so yeah that meant that makes sense get
ready this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready yeah
[Music]
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off